a
[Música]
este logo y estas fotografías
representaban para mi éxito dinero poder
independencia tiempo y ser mi propio
jefe estas fotos me las tomé como último
paso para acabar mi presentación la cual
iba a mandar a diferentes clientes a
diferentes empresas diferentes marcas
nunca creí que de la mano de todo esto
venía un camino de fracaso de crisis de
pobreza de falta de tiempo de
incertidumbre
de miedos
no venía de una empresa como bien lo
dijeron ahorita de ichán en donde hacía
lo que quería ayer la directora de
comunicación y relaciones públicas de la
marca tenía un logo gigante que me
respaldaba siempre hacía lo que quería
me sentaba con quien quería empresarios
claro que si juntas celebrities hagamos
una campaña sin dinero no paraba por
dinero tenía dinero para hacer campañas
para atraer gente internacional para
pues showroom ropa no hacía lo que
quería
después de estos seis años yo dije tengo
una gran idea y ahora sí estoy lista
para emprender no
vivimos en un mundo
en la era digital en un mundo de redes
sociales donde todo el mundo tiene el
mejor cuerpo los mejores outfits la
mejor relación la mejor el mejor
embarazo no hay nunca nadie enseña el
nado el lado difícil de la vida y la
vulnerabilidad y hoy yo vengo aquí no a
platicarles sobre lo maravilloso que es
emprender sino lo difícil que es
emprender me enfocaré en seis puntos que
a mí me hubiera encantado que alguien me
hubiera sentado y me hubiera dicho
punto número 1 aprender del fracaso no
se van a caer una vez ni dos veces ni
tres veces van a hacer muchas veces que
es lo importante de esto que saquen el
aprendizaje el mayor aprendizaje posible
y puedan seguir con esto historia
perfecta de éxito quien no conoce la
historia de phil knight creador de nike
y con su libro su box y no lo han leído
léanlo es un monstruo ustedes nada más
ven usted ni si ven la palomita y dicen
éste tuvo una gran idea y triunfo como
le hago yo no él estuvo más de 15 años
luchando estuvo más de 15 años
fracasando se les cerraron puertas se
les cerraron inversionistas fábricas le
dijeron que no hay socios empresarios de
todo el mundo y él se seguía levantando
aprendido del fracaso es muy importante
que aprendan del fracaso y que sepan que
van a fracasar en silicon valley eres
mucho más exitoso si fracasas a que si
no fracasas porque te vuelve mucho más
fuerte
se vuelve una persona que realmente
sabes reaccionar ante diferentes crisis
punto número 2 claridad en tuba y otra
vez la gente sale y dice tengo una gran
idea que quiero hacer esto como lo voy a
hacer esto y lo tienes muy claro pero
porque lo vas a hacer es importantísimo
que se hagan esta pregunta siempre
porque lo van a hacer no el ejemplo más
claro y perfecto es apple tiene
clarísimo su why que es pensar diferente
venden computadoras no como con un
diseño increíble pero cuál es su va a
pensar diferente cambiar el status quo
punto número 3 evolucionar siempre
avanzar y observar de tus errores
vivimos en una sociedad donde está
cambiando constantemente ya lo han
platicado antes todo lo que estamos
viviendo no estamos en una pandemia
mundial donde las marcas se están
renovando en donde las marcas están
viendo ahora cómo trabajar cómo conectar
con el consumidor final el mercado está
cambiando y debemos de observar mucho y
poder empezar de cero siempre observar
de cada uno de los errores que estamos
teniendo no un ejemplo perfecto para mí
ese bien vi donde pues un modelo de
negocio no era completamente diferente
donde observaron siempre sus errores qué
es lo que está pasando porque la gente
no se está quedando en los hospedajes
bien vendieron cereales hicieron no
tienen una historia increíble pero
siempre pensaban en evolucionar siempre
pensaban en avanzar y observar cada
error para regresar a esto no un ejemplo
de todo lo contrario que no estuvo
evolucionando donde no observada los
errores se cerraba no era muy work es we
work no quien se sabe la historia de we
work empezaron increíbles
y de repente inversiones gastos que no
tenían que hacer no escuchaban no vieron
todos los cambios que estaba pasando en
el mercado y entraron prácticamente en
bancarrota no o cuántas veces no nos
encaprichamos y no vemos los errores
ejemplo personal mío yo salí diciendo
hay aquí yo voy a salir ya tengo una
trayectoria increíble todo mundo me va a
contratar y te das cuenta que no sale si
buscas al director de no sé dónde a
todos tus contactos porque te dedicas a
hacer para para mí fueron 12 años de
buscar gente de encontrarme con gente de
hacer esos contactos y yo dije en el
momento que salga ese logo no me importa
no yo estoy lista le voy a hablar al
pierde no sé dónde le voy a hablar a mi
amigo empresarial y te topas con que no
entonces
estás ahí saliendo emprendiendo y es
importante eso observar los errores yo
decía después de esto no aceptó una
propuesta que no esté arriba de los 500
mil pesos yo ya no voy a hacer yo solo
quiero hacer creación de contenido sólo
quiero hacer influencer marketing y
rechace al principio de mi carrera como
emprendedor a muchas propuestas vea pues
hacer este tipo de piedras y no yo ya no
hago piar vea me puedes hacer una
campaña así tengo 50 mil pesos no yo
arriba de los 500 mil pesos y de repente
me tope y decir ok ya llevo un año
emprendiendo y que he hecho
una campaña
es importantísimo ver tus errores en el
momento que yo me di cuenta dije quién
te crees quién te crees
hay que observar estos errores empecé a
escuchar empecé a tomar propuestas donde
me decían oye ayúdame con este pillar
claro que sí claro que sí no entramos a
esta pandemia mundial donde bien lo
comentaban mis compañeros es lo que
tenemos que hacer no entonces empecé a
escuchar observar de mis errores y trate
de evolucionar siempre y hoy sigo en ese
camino sigo en este camino de
emprendimiento sigo en ese camino de
lucha constante en el cual espero pueda
triunfar en algún momento punto número 4
acostúmbrate al no lo mismo sales y
dices ah y me va a contestar el teléfono
el pierde no sé qué marca acá el
director de marketing acá el empresario
acá el célebre y es uno constante
no se pueden hundir con los dos porque
va a ser siempre uno harry potters quien
no conoce harry potter
doce editoriales lo rechazaron
doce editoriales él pudo haber tirado la
toalla a la tercera y decir ya mi libro
va a ser un fracaso no lo están tomando
si no lo están tomando es por algo y va
a seguir pasando entonces acostúmbrense
al no un libro que me decía omar
interesantísimo que se llama reed y
jackson proof
lo estuve leyendo se estuve viendo su
usted y lo mismo no él dice que va a
poner en prueba 100 diferentes acciones
donde la gente le diga que no y te das
cuenta todo el aprendizaje que generas a
través de uno si te dicen que si a la
primera que pasa a perfecto ya soy una
chingona a perfecto ya hice esto también
te dice no y buscas cómo avanzar te dice
no y buscas cómo cambiar te dice no y
vas observando porque es el no y ese es
el aprendizaje que debes de tener día
con día de porque te están diciendo que
no y cómo puedes avanzar
punto número 5 confiar en tu instinto
cuántas veces no se nos olvida nuestro
nuestro propio instinto empiezas a
escuchar a otras opiniones
empiezas a obsesionarte empiezas a decir
no yo a fuerza quiero trabajar con esta
persona oa fuerza quiero hacer este tipo
de campañas oa fuerza voy a hacer esta
propuesta no y dejas de confiar en tu
instinto yo tengo un ejemplo claro donde
yo decía una marca de relojes quiero
hacer su campaña a ver me hace una
propuesta bueno un tiempo le dedique
dinero para presentarles la mejor
propuesta no esté increíble va a dejar
la mando a suiza ok
vea la puedes mandar ahora en inglés
claro vea le puedes bajar el siempre el
cien por ciento del presupuesto claro yo
sabía que no la iba a tener yo sabía mi
instinto me lo decía esta marca no te va
a dar el proyecto y yo seguía
invirtiendo tiempo y dinero en esto
entonces es importantísimo con ciento
instinto conclusión no me la dieron
nunca hice tres propuestas diferentes
gasté una cantidad
el tiempo y no la tuve entonces es
importante confiar en su instinto
siempre tu instinto lo sabe
perfectamente cuando hay una oportunidad
confíen en eso es punks nos dicen no sé
si sepan que ese es punks pues la marca
de pajas líderes en el mundo no sabe el
blakely ella es la creadora toda su
historia si le escuchan es de confiar en
su instinto ella confiaba rechazos y le
decían no tienes que llevar este proceso
no yo confío en mí yo confío en que si
me presento va a ser así y se presentaba
en bloomingdale's y le daban la cita iba
a las maquilas oye quiere una faja si no
es que para que funcione esa franja de
tierra oye no yo confío en mi instinto
yo confío en mi proyecto y quiero que la
faja sea así así así entonces es
importante que siempre confíen en
ustedes siempre confíen en su instinto
punto número 6 priorizar tu tiempo
[Música]
cuanto tiempo perdemos haciendo
absolutamente todo bien lo decía david
no antes 80 eventos sociales 80 juntas
levante la mano quien aquí yo tenía jum
titís no era junto a las 9 la mañana 10
de la mañana a 11 de la mañana 12 123
tenías una hora para comer vivíamos así
gracias al cob y gracias a la situación
actual no hemos aprendido a priorizar
los tiempos creo que es importantísimo
eso importantísimo
tesla
no sé si han leído pero tiene su five
minutes no tiene una regla de cinco
minutos separa su bloque
se separa en cinco bloques y esos cinco
bloques cinco minutos cada cosa él dice
que en cinco minutos puede hacer
absolutamente todo contestar un correo
tener lonche estar con su familia tener
una junta que en cinco minutos puedes
hacer absolutamente todo y subir tu
productividad perdemos mucho tiempo
haciendo cosas que no vienen al caso
entonces prioricen su tiempo dediquen el
tiempo que necesitan a sus cosas y
háganlo rápido no entonces estos son los
seis puntos que a mí me hubiera servido
muchísimo que alguien me los hubiera
dado
se tienen que arriesgar
méxico necesita de más emprendedores es
subir un barco difícil un barco que se
va a hundir varias veces pero que va a
salir a flote necesitan emprender
necesitan fracasar necesitan atreverse
muchas veces por miedo no nos atrevemos
y tienes que enfrentarte a ese miedo
necesitamos emprender no tienen que
emprender con una empresa y una idea
maravillosa claro que la ciudad son
difíciles llevan un sueño a la ejecución
es difícil pueden emprender en su
trabajo actual bien lo decían
acá mi compañero no en liverpool todos
los días puedes emprender en tu trabajo
todos los días puedes emprender afuera
todos los días puedes generar ideas
nuevas
es importante que emprendan y no se
duerman
hicieron un estudio
enfermos terminales donde les
preguntaban que de qué se arrepienten
que qué es lo que harían diferente si
tuvieran otra vez la oportunidad de
vivir el 80 por ciento respondió que
arriesgarían más
entonces quédense con eso por favor
emprender es el camino que recorrido no
el resultado final es ser el cuate
estuve buscando coach para cerrar esta
conferencia donde yo decía quiero que
algún empresario dijo un court y lo dije
no yo voy a generar ese cuento porque
para mí emprender es ese camino que he
recorrido hasta el día de hoy y que sigo
en ese camino donde me topado con pared
muchísimo donde sigo con miedo donde se
me han caído 300 propuestas donde no he
podido pagar sueldos
pero es ese camino el que te hace
levantarte varias veces y ese es el
resultado final muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]